N
NORTH IS JIM MARTHA'S BILLIARD
WHILE TENURED.
>> AT LEAST 48 HOURS.
LET'S CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION
I BRING IT LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
TEXAS DAN PATRICK THIS MORNING.
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR GRAY TAG ON
THE PROGRAM.
LET'S DO THIS.
I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR YOU, AND
YOUR WORDS EXPLAIN FOR ANYONE
WHO MIGHT BE CONFUSED THE
PURPOSE OF SENDING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS TO PLACES LIKE
MARTHA'S VINEYARD, CHICAGO, OR
NEW YORK.
>> THANKS A WILL AND GOOD TO BE
ON WITH YOU ALL AGAIN.
THIS IS CAMPAIGN SEASON.
WITH THE ELECTION COMING UP I AM
TRAVELING TO 130 CITIES AROUND
RURAL TEXAS.
THAT IS WHERE THE VOTE IS IS TO
GET OUT LIKE MOST STATES.
WORLD TEXAS IS A VERY RED.
AND EVERYWHERE I GO THE NUMBER
ONE ISSUE THEY SAY TO ME IS WE
HAVE TO SECURE THE BORDER.
EVERYWHERE.
BEEN TO 35 CITIES THIS WEEK.
NOT ONLY THAT BUT THEY SAY KEEP
THE BUSES GOING, DAN.
THE REASON WE ARE SENDING THE
BUSES IS WE DO WANT TO SEND A
MESSAGE AND HOPEFULLY THESE BLUE
DEMOCRATS IN THESE CITIES AND
THESE GOVERNORS AND THESE ARE
BLUE STATES WILL PUT ENOUGH
PRESSURE ON THE PRESIDENT TO SAY
MR. PRESIDENT, YOU ARE OBVIOUSLY
WRONG.
THE BORDER IS NOT SECURE.
YOU NEED TO HELP US STOP THIS.
I DON'T CARE WHAT CRYING THEY
ARE DOING.
THEY CAN CRY IN THEIR BEER ALL
DAY LONG.
AND THE PEOPLE OF MARTHA'S
VINEYARD WHAT A BUNCH OF ELITIST
HYPOCRITES THEY ARE.
BUT THEY HAVE DONE IS SIGNALED
TO US WE NEED TO SEND MORE BUSES
TO PLACES LIKE HOLLYWOOD OR BEL
AIR.
MAY BEAT BARBRA STREISAND HAD A
GREAT SONG IN THE 70s.
PEOPLE I NEED BE BUT WE WILL
SEND HER SOME PEOPLE TO HER
STREET.
BECAUSE SHE AND THE LEFTIST
HOLLYWOOD CROWD AND THE ELITISTS
ON THE EAST COAST AND OTHER
PLACES AROUND AMERICA THEY
SUPPORT ALL THESE POLICIES.
THAT EVERYONE COME IN BUT WE ARE
A SANCTUARY CITY.
WE LOVE THESE PEOPLE.
AS SOON AS THEY ACTUALLY GOT OFF
THE BUS TO GET AWAY FOR ME, GET
AWAY FOR ME.
WE DO NOT WANT THEM IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD.
LET THEM OWN WHAT THEY SUPPORT.
THEY NEED TO OWN UP WHAT THEY
SUPPORT.
LET THEM UNDERSTAND WHAT OUR
PEOPLE ARE DEALING WITH.
ESPECIALLY IN OUR BORDER TOWNS
WERE WE ARE OVERRUN EVERY DAY.
RACHAEL: TO SET ON THE SHOW
EARLY SAID THIS IS JUST A STUNT.
WHEN GOVERNOR ABBOTT -- MIKE I
THINK IT'S BEEN VERY EFFECTIVE.
I DON'T THINK IT'S BEEN MORE
EFFECTIVE THAN ON MARTHA'S
VINEYARD.
I THINK IT ALSO EXPOSES AS YOU
SAID THE ELITISTS IN.
THEY LIKE THESE ARE BROWN PEOPLE
TO WORK IN THEIR HOMES BUT NOT
TO ACTUALLY BE ON THEIR
BEAUTIFUL ISLANDS.
AND SO THEY GOT RID OF THEM
QUICKLY.
NOW, MY QUESTION TO YOU IS AS
MUCH AS I LIKE WHAT I'VE SEEN IN
TERMS OF EXPOSING THIS POLICY
AND BRINGING THE BORDER TO SOME
OF THE NEIGHBORHOODS, I AM
WONDERING WHY THE STATE OF TEXAS
JUST NEVER DECLARED A STATE OF
EMERGENCY.
SO INSTEAD OF FEELING HELPLESS
THIS IS ALL WE CAN DO IS SEND
THEM TO THESE OTHER PLACES.
THAT THEY WOULD NOT NORMALLY GO
TO MAYBE WE COULD STOP IT BEFORE
IT EVEN HAPPENS.
IN MY BEING A POLLYANNA HERE?
>> YOU CANNOT STOP IT BEFORE IT
HAPPENS BECAUSE THE SUPREME
COURT ALREADY DECLARED AND THE
CASE OF SEVERAL AGO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AT LEAST AT THIS
POINT HAS A PURVIEW OVER THE
ACTUAL BORDER.
BUT WHEN THEY DO NOT DO THEIR
JOB WE ARE IN A STATE OF
EMERGENCY.
WE HAVE TO ABSORB ALL THE DRUGS
THAT COME IN.
THEY KILL OUR KIDS.
WE HAVE TO ABSORB ALL THE PEOPLE
THAT COME INTO OVERRUN TOWNS
LIKE DEL RIO A POPULATION OF
37000 PEOPLE THAT HAVE 400,000
PEOPLE IN THEIR SECTOR.
THAT WOULD BE LIKE NEW YORK
GETTING TEN TIMES THEIR
POPULATION OR 80 MILLION PEOPLE.
SO, WE HAVE BEEN IN A CONSTANT
STATE OF EMERGENCY BECAUSE
CRIMINALS CROSSING THE BORDER.
TERRORISTS CROSSING THE BORDER.
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE COMING INTO
OUR STATE EVERY DAY.
THEY ARE CRYING THEY HAVE HAD
10,000 PEOPLE ON BUSES OR SO
SINCE THE BEGINNING.
WE HAVE THAT ALMOST EVERY DAY.
I HAVE NO SYMPATHY FOR THESE
ELITIST LEFTISTS LIBERAL
DEMOCRATS.
NONE WHATSOEVER.
I CARE ABOUT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
AND UNTIL THEY FEEL THE SAME
PAIN TEXANS ARE FEELING, UNTIL
THEY HAVE TO DEAL THE SAME
THINGS WE ARE DEALING WITH, IT
IS NOT UNTIL THEN THEY'LL PUT
PRESSURE ON THEIR SENATORS AND
THEIR CONGRESSMEN IN THE
DEMOCRAT STATES DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT.
BECAUSE THIS HAS TO END.
>> IS TO FOLLOW UP ON RACHEL'S
QUESTION I THINK WE ALL AGREE
THE IMPACT AND THE SPOTLIGHT
BEING SHOWN ON THIS CRISIS BY
SHIPPING ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS TO
BLUE STATES AND BLUE CITIES IS
OBVIOUSLY EFFECTIVE.
BUT TO THE GOAL BEING, AS YOU
STATED, TO PRESSURE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT INTO SOLVING THE
PROBLEM.
IN LIEU OF THAT, I DO NOT WANT
TO SPEAK ON YOUR BEHALF BUT
THERE IS AN ARGUMENT BEING MADE
YOU COULD DECLARE AN INVASION.
YOU HAVE THAT CONSTITUTIONAL
POWER TO BEGIN TO DEPORT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS BACK TO MEXICO.
IF YOU HAVE THAT LEGAL QUESTION
TAKE THAT TO THE SUPREME COURT.
IS THAT NOT A PATH TO ACTUALLY
SOLVING THE CRISIS THAT EXIST AT
YOUR BORDER?
>> SO, I'VE BEEN SAYING THIS FOR
A LONG TIME, MANY YEARS I'VE
BEEN ON FOX MANY TIMES OVER THE
YEARS.
I'VE BEEN CALLING THIS AN
INVASION FOR A LONG TIME.
WE ARE AT A POINT RIGHT NOW WHAT
MIT DID A STUDY IN 2016 I SEE
THIS ON THE SHOW BEFORE.
THAT WAS BACK IN 2016.
IT'S NOT 11 MILLION PEOPLE YOU
ALWAYS HERE FOR 25 -- 30,000,007
YEARS AGO.
WE ARE OFF WITH THE MIT TO
35 MILLION NOW THAT IS
APPREHENDED.
WHEN I GO AROUND ON MY TOUR WANT
TO HEAR FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
THIS AFTERNOON WE CATCH ONE OUT
OF TWO OR THREE YOU CAN DOUBLE
OR TRIPLE THAT.
IN ADDITION TO THAT AND JOE
BIDEN'S FIRST YEAR WE HAD
2 MILLION WE APPREHENDED THE
FIRST YEAR.
2 MILLION THIS YEAR THAT WE WILL
APPREHEND PLUS THE GOT A WAYS.
WE ARE APPROACHING TEN -- 15% OF
THE TOTAL POPULATION IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA WILL BE
HERE ILLEGALLY BY THE TIME JOE
BIDEN'S FIRST TERM IS OVER.
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THIS HAS
BEEN AN INVASION FOR A LONG
TIME.
THIS IS A PLAN BY THE LEFT.
THEY WANT TO BRING PEOPLE IN,
EVENTUALLY ONE DATE MAKE SURE
THEY ALL HAVE CITIZENSHIP SO
THEY CAN VOTE.
PEOPLE WHO ARE COMING HERE
ILLEGALLY IS A PLAN.
THIS IS NOT AN ACCIDENT BY THE
FACT THEY'RE ANGRY ABOUT OR
SHINING A LIGHT ON IT.
I HOPE THAT WE CAN DO IS CREATE
ANOTHER CASE.
BACK IN THE LEGISLATIVE SESSION
IN JANUARY THAT WE CAN GET TO
THE SUPREME COURT TO DETERMINE
THIS ONE MORE TIME.
AND MAYBE THIS COURT WILL
RECOGNIZE THAT WE DO HAVE A
RIGHT TO PROTECT OUR CITIZENS ON
THE BORDER RIGHT ON THE RIVER.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO PROTECT
OUR PEOPLE.
>> AT THE FINE POINTS.
YOU MENTIONED IS SAYING IT IS
INVASION BUT WE ALL ACKNOWLEDGE
AND SAY IT IS.
BUT IS THERE A FORMER ATTEMPT
FORMAL DECLARATION TEXAS SHOULD
OR CAN MAKE CUSTOMER DOES NOT
HAPPEN FROM THE GOVERNOR?
FROM THE LEGISLATURE?
HOW DOES A SUPREME COURT
SHOWDOWN HAPPEN IF TAXES WERE TO
FORMALLY SAY WERE BEING INVADED?
>> LOOK, THE GOVERNOR WILL MAKE
THAT DECISION.
BUT THE ANSWER FOR IT
LEGISLATURE I'M PRESIDENT OF THE
SENATE.
IT IS TO CRAFT A BILL SIMILAR I
DON'T SAY SIMILAR TO ARIZONA,
BUT TO MAKE THE CASE THAT WE
HAVE THIS LEGAL RIGHT TO STAND
THERE AND PROTECT OUR BORDER.
LOOK, WE CAN SEND THE BUSES TO
GET ATTENTION.
WE CAN MAKE COMMENTS.
BUT LET'S LOOK AT WHAT WE ARE
DEALING WITH.
WE ARE DOING WITH FENTANYL
COMING OVER THE BORDER.
IN SUCH AMOUNTS THAT'S THE
NUMBER ONE KILLER OF YOUNG
PEOPLE OF 45.
THAT IS NOT A LAUGHING MATTER OR
A JOKING MATTER.
THAT HIS DEATH.
FAMILIES ARE EXPANDING YOUNG
PEOPLE DYING THEY GOT THE WRONG
PILL THAT WAS SENT OVER THE
BORDER.
WE HAVE CRIMINALS CROSSING THE
BORDER PUT MS 13 GANG MEMBER'S
CROSSING THE BORDER, TERRORISTS
CROSSING THE BORDER FOR THE ONLY
THREE PEOPLE ON THE PLANET THAT
THINK IT IS SECURE ARE THE
PRESIDENT, THE VICE PRESIDENT
AND THE SECRETARY OF HOMELAND
SECURITY.
IN THE MOUTHPIECE FOR ALDEN THAT
SHOWS UP AT THE WHITE HOUSE
IMPRESSIVE BRIEFINGS EVERY DAY
THAT IS NOT EVER TELL THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THE TRUTH.
THE ONLY SITE ON THE BORDER IS
SECURE IS THE OTHER SIDE BY THE
WAY.
UNDERSTAND THIS NO ONE CROSSES
THAT BORDER UNLESS THEY PAY
THEIR MONEY TO THE CARTELS.
THE CARTELS HAVE TOTAL CONTROL
OF THE BORDER.
THEY HAVE SECURED THEIR SIDE.
WE NEED TO SECURE OUR SIDE.
WE WANT LEGISLATION TO DOUBLE GO
UP TO THE SUPREME COURT.
TO DECLARE THAT ONCE AND FOR ALL
PER THERE'S NO AMBIGUITY
WHATSOEVER.
THIS HAS TO END.
>> THERE BE A CONSTITUTIONAL
CRISIS THAT I'M JUST CURIOUS IF
YOU PASS THAT BILL I AM A TEXAN.
WE WANT TO SEE PEACOCKS GLAD TO
HAVE APRICOTS BORN AND RAISED.
WE WANT TO SEE THIS SOLVED LIKE
EVERYONE.
I AM CURIOUS THE BILL YOU PLAN
TO CRAFT A SET UP OUR TEXAS DPS
OR TEXAS RANGERS TO DEPORT
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS?
>> RIGHT NOW THAT'S THREE MONTHS
AWAY SO LET US WRITE THE BILL.
WE WILL WRITE STRONG LEGISLATION
THAT MAKES SURE THERE IS NO
QUESTION THAT WE HAVE A RIGHT TO
PROTECT OUR CITIZENS.
THERE IS NO ARGUMENTS.
THE BEST WAY TO WIN THIS IS TO
BE SURE THAT EVERY STATE IN
PARTICULAR THE BORDER STATES
HAVE A RIGHT TO DEFEND OUR
CITIZENS FOR.
>> TO INCLUDE DEPORTATION?
>> GUYS, LET MEET WRITE A BILL
FIRST-RATE LET'S NOT WRITE IT
HERE ON THE AIR ON SATURDAY
MORNING.
WHEN YOU WRITE A CONSTITUTIONAL
BILL LIKE WE WERE AT THE
HEARTBEAT BILL THAT SURVIVED A
SUPREME COURT SCRUTINY.
THAT BILL BECAME LAW.
WRITING A LEGISLATION THAT
CHANGES THE CONSTITUTION IS VERY
SERIOUS BUSINESS.
VERY SERIOUS BUSINESS TO TAKE
TOP SCHOLARS, TAKES A LOT OF
THOUGHT AND A LOT OF WORK.
NOT SOMETHING THE THREAT HERE ON
THE TV SHOWS THEY WERE GOING TO
DO THIS.
I AM SERIOUS ABOUT THIS.
THE LEGISLATURES ARE SERIOUS
ABOUT THIS BUT THE PEOPLE OF
TEXAS ARE SERIOUS ABOUT THIS.
BUT THIS IN PERSPECTIVE TO ALL
OF THESE WHINY BABIES UP IN THE
BLUE STATES, THIS IS SUCH A
CRISIS BUT WE NORMALLY SPEND
400 MILLION YEAR ON BORDER
SECURITY.
WE ARE SPENDING OVER $4 BILLION
OF TEXAS TAXPAYER MONEY.
MANDATE WE GET SPENT ON
HEALTHCARE, EDUCATION, ROADS,
WHATEVER IT MIGHT BE.
$4 BILLION A YEAR.
WE HAVE OUR NATIONAL GUARD THERE
ON THE BORDER.
THIS IS A FINANCIAL BURDEN ON
US.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY IT IS AN
INVASION OF OUR STAY.
I'VE SAID IT FOR A LONG TIME I'M
NOT SHY ABOUT THE WORD.
BUT WE HAVE TO DO THIS THE RIGHT
WAY.
I WILL ALSO PROPOSE THAT SINCE
WE ARE SPENDING SO MUCH OF
MONEY, I WOULD LIKE THE HIGHER
EVERY BORDER PATROL AGENT ON THE
BOARD APPROVED EVERY ONE OF
THEM, THERE ARE ABOUT 8000.
WE COULD AFFORD TO DO IT.
HIRE THEM AND MAKE A NEW STATE
BORDER GUARD SO THAT JOE BIDEN
DOES NOT HAVE ONE PERSON LEFT.
AND BY THE WAY THE BORDER PATROL
AGENTS THEY ARE HEROES IN MY
BOOK.
THEY HATE WORKING FOR THIS GUY.
I THINK THEY WOULD LOVE WORKING
FOR TEXAS.
AND THEN LET THEM LOOK AROUND
AND FIND THERE'S NOBODY THERE TO
EVEN DO THE JOB.
WE'LL JUST SAY MR. PRESIDENT, WE
WILL TAKE IT OVER.
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THIS OUR
FOUNDING FATHERS AND NEVER
BELIEVED TO BE A PRESIDENT ONE
DAY.
THAT'S WHY THE CONSTITUTION IS
WRITTEN LIKE IT IS BUT THEY
ASSUME THE PRESIDENT OF THE
NIGHT STATES WOULD DEFEND OUR
NATION'S BORDERS.
THEY NEVER IMAGINED A PRESIDENT
LIKE THIS WOULD TURN THEIR BACK
ON THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY TURNED THEIR BACK ON THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THEY ARE DYING
BECAUSE OF IT.
IN EVERY PLACE THAT WE SEE IT WE
ARE BEING OVERRUN.
AND JUST REMEMBER THIS BUT THEY
SENT THEM TO A MILITARY BASE ON
MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
I'VE ALWAYS ASKED THIS QUESTION
AND ON THE SHOW BEFORE, EXACTLY
WHAT IS BIDEN'S ANSWER WHEN WE
SAY WORD OF THESE PEOPLE GO?
OR DO THEY ACTUALLY GO?
HOW DID THEY LIVE?
DO THEY MOVE IN WITH SOMEONE YOU
CAN'T PUT A 15-YEAR-OLD AND
FOURTH GRADER TWO OR THREE
GRADES BEHIND.
WHAT ARE THEY DO FOR WORK AND?
THEY DON'T HAVE A LEGAL PERMIT.
THEY HAVE BEEN DUMPING PEOPLE IN
AMERICA FOR A LONG TIME.
A LONG TIME.
AND NOW TEXAS IS SAYING WE ARE
FIGHTING BACK.
WERE GOING TO SEND THEM TO YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD WERE GOING TO KEEP
THOSE BUSES COMING UNTIL FINALLY
THIS ADMINISTRATION WAKES UP.
AND THEN WE WILL PASS
LEGISLATION NEXT SESSION THAT
WILL HOPEFULLY GET US TO THE
SUPREME COURT WHERE THIS SUPREME
COURT CAN RULE THAT TEXAS AND
EVERYONE ELSE HAS A RIGHT TO
PROTECT THEIR CITIZENS.
AND THEN WE CAN DO IT.
REDOING THE BEST WE CAN NOW
UNDER TOUGH CIRCUMSTANCES.
RACHAEL: NO DOUBT THEY ARE TOUGH
CIRCUMSTANCES.
YOU ARE DOING THE BEST YOU CAN.
WE FEEL IT.
THE MOST INFURIATING PART IS
JUST HOW THE OTHER SIDE, THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE A WRAP THIS UP
INTO COMPASSION.
>> THEY HAVE NO COMPASSION.
>> I BELIEVE THEY HAVE EXPOSE
THEIR HYPOCRISY ON A LEVEL EVEN
WE WERE SURPRISED BY.
WE THANK YOU FOR THAT.
>> CAN I ADD ONE MORE POINT?
>> PEOPLE ASK ME ALL THE TIME,
WHY AREN'T YOU SENDING THEM TO
DELAWARE QUESTION WHAT WE CANNOT
FIND ANYONE CROSSING THE BORDER
WHO WANTS TO GO THAT'S ALL I CAN
TELL YOU.
>> LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR IS A
POINT OF CLARIFICATION, MORE
BUSES GOING.
KERRI SKINNER TELLS WHERE?
>> NO OF COURSE NOT.
WHAT I DID SAY ON THE SHOW A
MONTH OR SO AGO I DID SAY WHEN
IT'S JUST NEW YORK IN WASHINGTON
I SAID IF YOU ARE A DEMOCRAT
GOVERNOR OR MAYOR, YOU BETTER
KEEP LOOKING OUT YOUR WINDOW.
MORE BUSES ARE COMING TO
DIFFERENT PLACES.
I THINK THAT WAS TRUE TO MY
WORD.
>> LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR MAY I
MAKE THIS SUGGESTION TO AOC'S
DISTRICT AND ALSO TO HER
APARTMENT BUT SHE LIVES ABOVE A
WHOLE FOODS.
I THINK THAT WILL BE A GOOD
SPOT.
SHE WENT TO TO TEXAS TO CRY AT A
DETENTION CENTER.
AND I NEVER SAW ANYTHING OUT OF
HER AFTER THE 50 MIGRANTS DIED
BASICALLY BURNED ALIVE IN THAT
TRUCK.
AND NOW SHE JUST PUT OUT A TWEET
SAYING THIS IS HUMANITARIAN
CRISES.
HUMAN RIGHTS AND EVERYTHING ELSE
BECAUSE OF THESE TRUCKS GOING --
BUSES GOING TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD
ET CETERA.
COOKS WELL, I THINK THAT'S A
GOOD NAME TO ADD TO THE LIST.
SEE BARBRA STREISAND SHOW UP ON
HER CURBSIDE IN HER SLIPPER
SAYING HEY COME ONTO MY HOUSE.
THAT WILL BE THE DAVID.
>> IS ONGOING WE COVERED IT JUST
THIS MORNING AT ABOUT 6:30 A.M.
GET ANOTHER BUS FROM TEXAS RIGHT
IN FRONT OF THE VI